QUESTION: A lot of Ursula Le Guin's world-building
is pretty political like The Dispossessed...
How did that influence you?
And was that something you ever discussed?
And do you think it explicitly colored
your approach to the Mars Trilogy?
Kim Stanley Robinson: Well, thank you for that.
Yes, yes, and yes.
I'm glad you brought it up. Because if I'd had more time I'd have talked about it. And I will now.
Ursula's politics were American leftist
of a different variety than mine.
But we were both the kind of American leftist
that said, look, the front is broad
and we just take our different points of view and work together rather than the narcissism of small differences
where the leftists fight leftists because they're the only people that understand the nature of the argument.
The Dispossessed is an anarchist text.
And it is an interesting, compelling thought experiment:
What would it be like to live in an anarchist society?
Because really anarchism is almost politically autistic
where everybody's free and in everybody free contract between everybody and there are no rules...
She actually wrote an email to thank me
for my introduction to Magpie Killjoy's
anarchist (book "Mythmakers & Lawbreakers").
I wrote the introduction.
I said, anarchy can mean
"no rules" or "no ruler" in the Greek.
I say it means no ruler because you have to have rules.
And even on Anarres,
there's rules in the anarchistic society.
It's like management of the Commons.
The Commons was not a space where
you could do anything.
It was managed and regulated.
And anarchism as I understand it will be a complete horizontalization of power and wealth.
That's the anarchist goal. A distant horizon
that everybody should be shooting for.
So, she and I came at it from our different angles.
I'm much more of a Marxist-Leninist, and a statist.
Her anarchism, as she told me,
came out of the Tao Te Ching.
Her translation of the Tao Te Ching is fabulously good.
You need to cross-reference it with three or four others to realize how amorphous and murky that document is.
But she comes to anarchism from the Tao.
And from that strain of Chinese literature that I think comes also from her father
and the anthropological strain.
I stayed up all night to read The Dispossessed.
I had a little science fiction library club hardback. It was short and light. I got to what I call the Dickinson point.
Which is the point where you know you have
to finish this book in that sitting.
It comes from Peter Dickinson, who does it all the time.
But I got to that point with her and it was 1AM.
So I stayed up to like 4AM to read The Dispossessed.
And when I was done, I was thinking: you can write a utopian novel and make it work as a novel.
And that blew my mind.
That was 1975.
And it was a huge impact on the Mars Trilogy.
And everything that I've done since.
Probably in terms of the content--
rather than the form--the content.
Her influence comes to me mostly from Left Hand of Darkness and from The Dispossessed.
As gender + politics...
She was really important and I know still is to anarchists and American leftists who are thinking about it.
So thank you.
McElligott: When you look at Left Hand of Darkness.
It's a novel about refugees and culture clash.
It's a novel about gender and levels of trust.
It's a novel where a society sees a potential to progress that's offered and isn't sure if it's going to take the offer.
I mean two societies on that planet. So it's an interesting foil for the moment we're in now.
Robinson: Left Hand of Darkness is a great novel.
I would say it's her masterpiece.
And one of the great novels of the 20th century.
And it has to do with a couple of things.
Karhide is feudal.
The other society, on the other side of the world,
is socialist.
In a bad Soviet totalitarian way.
There isn't a capitalist society.
There's only these two struggling.
And both of them mired in their problems.
So it has a lot of interesting political thoughts.
I think she was thinking...
that maybe the two of them together was a portrait of the United States in the 1960s.
Partly feudal and partly bad socialism.
But no function. No real culture.
And then the gender thing for me was that
most of the time gender isn't important for social life.
Sometimes it is. Pay attention to that.
And when my wife and I had our first kid...
she's a scientist working 12 hours a day, six days a week. And when my boy was 10-weeks old
I took over. And was a caretaker of this child.
Mr. Mom as they put it
in the great movie by Michael Keaton.
I was Mr. Mom for years.
In The Left Hand of Darkness this idea
the king was pregnant, which obviously I wasn't.
But the King did a lot of bottle feedings.
They were very maternal in their affect.
And I thought, yeah man.
Left Hand helped me to conceptualize
the feelings that I had.
The structure of feeling had changed
because of that book.
So I was just in... kemmer had come along
and I was in my female existence.
And I was really happy. I thought I was pretty good at it.
This is profound, what literature can do for you.
And she knew that.
I think she knew that she had hit it
out of the park with that book.